does your infrastructure consist of  several different elements such as  compute engine instances cloud storage  buckets and Cloud routers how do you  configure these elements what are  resources in the terraform environment  learn more about it in this short  resources are infrastructure elements  including instances firewall rules and  Cloud routers individual resources are  declared in a resource block  a resource is identified by the resource  keyword followed by the resource type  and the resource name  terraform configurations can contain  multiple resources and multiple resource  types and these types can even spawn  across multiple providers a single  resource block is used to define a  single resource type  are you ready to learn more click on the  three dots and then click on the link in  description box to enroll in the getting  started with terraform for Google Cloud  course see you there